-So, I feel as though
the last time you were on,
we were talking
about the fact that
we were pretty quickly
going to have a nominee
for the Democratic Party
and all the news would shift
to the horse race
of the presidential election
That has not been the case
Is it surreal to you,
having covered this
from the very beginning,
how certainly the Democratic
primary resolved itself?
-It's so surreal
to think about,
you know, 15 or 16 months
of intense focus.
I mean, Kamala Harris'
big announcement in the Bay Area
with thousands of people
and the first debate
and the second debate
and, you know,
John Delaney getting
his butt kicked
[Chuckling]
by Elizabeth Warren --
that all of that converged
to a video
probably shot on an iPad in th
Vermont house of Bernie Sanders,
beamed to the world amidst
the worst pandemic in 100 year
and the economy
on total lockdown
and half of the world's
population essentially shelt--
Like, who -- It's --
It was incomprehensible that
this is where it would end up,
but this is where it's ended up.
And so, there's naturally
this way in which I think the --
the urgency of the virus
is blotting out campaign news.
But, also, it's completely
recast the dynamics of the race.
I mean, the assumption
for those 15 months
and through impeachment was --
the fundamentals are,
this man is unpopular.
He's never been above 50%.
He won with 46% of the vot
last time,
but the economy is doing,
in a macro sense, pretty well --
what does that mean
for the election?
That is not the election
that we're having anymore.
So part of it is I think peopl
haven't even gotten
their hands around,
I certainly haven't
gotten my head around,
what is this election?
What's the substance of it
Because the future
is so uncertain.
I don't know what June
looks like.
And I don't --
I sure as hell don't know
what October looks like.
-It did seem as though the party
coalesced around the idea
of Biden as the candidate
as sort of the safest contrast
to Donald Trump,
like maybe not
the most idea-driven candidate
-Yes.
-Hopefully I'm not being unfai
in saying that.
-No, I think --
-And yet,
now we're in a situation
that it is only contrast.
It seems as though Joe Biden
who has not necessarily been out
as much as you would expec
a nominee for the presidency
to be out in public --
it seems like he's maybe
just stepping back
and letting people
see the contrast.
-I think that's part of it
I mean, I do think that --
look, one way to think about i
is all re-election campaigns
are referendums
on the incumbent, unavoidably.
That dynamic seems like
it's going to be supersize
in this case.
I mean, it's going to be
a referendum on the incumben
and his handling of this
once-a-century calamity.
[ Chuckles ]
And so, at a certain level
it's like -- it is a,
"Do you want to keep going
with this guy or not?"
kind of election.
And you have to be present
in illuminating your own ideas
I think, as the opposition party
and as the opposition candidate.
But it's also the case
that, like,
I think that dynamic
fundamentally
is a pretty inescapable on
at this point.
-Can you talk real quick about
what happened in Wisconsin
Because again, I think it go
dwarfed, obviously,
by pandemic news.
But it was a really, truly -
first,
crazy that the primary was held.
And then sort of the outcome
seemed to be the reverse
to what a lot of people
were expecting
based on the fact
that the election didn't help.
-It was -- It was such a -
I found it to be
a really upsetting undertaking
like, shockingly cynical.
The basic dynamics were --
and I --
you know, back on March 17th
I think were the last big
Democratic primary elections
And that -- things were --
it was a little unclear
they should have
gone forward then.
We since heard the poll worker
in Illinois died.
By the end --
but right up to that, I thought,
"This is not a good idea."
But a month later,
when everything has dawned
on everyone
and we're now all --
I'm talking to you,
you know, through
a computer screen, right?
That for the Republicans
to think
a low-turnout,
more difficult election
will aid their chances
of winning
a state supreme court race -
and if you want to vote,
then get out there, Milwaukee,
and stand in line with a mask,
is so shockingly cynical
and monstrous
that I could not believe
they did it, but they did it
and then everyone just assumed
that those turnout effects
would help the Republican,
and the Republican kind of
got his ass kicked.
Like, he lost by 10 points
I mean, Donald Trump
won Wisconsin by 23,000 votes.
The liberal challenger
in this race
who was running against
an incumbent
won by over 100,000 votes.
I mean, this was a big, big wi
for the Democrats
and liberals broadly
in Wisconsin.
And I still don't really hav
my arms around why it happened
We talked to Ben Wikler,
the chair of the
Democratic Party, last night
I think part of it was
people were really furious
and pissed off that,
in the midst of pandemic,
some people were, like, trying
to rig the game against them
-Well, it does seems
like a bad bellwether
for the Republican Party.
But I think,
as you referenced earlier,
it's impossible to know,
based on anything
that happens this week,
what that means in June,
what that means in October
Do you feel like the Democrats
re doing enough right now
to protect the election
in November?
-That's a huge worry,
and the answer is probably no.
Although it is not that
they haven't tried --
it's --
they haven't prioritized it.
So there's a fight
in the CARES Act,
which was the last rescue bill
that was passed,
over funding
for universal mail-in voting
And Democrats --
Mitch McConnell's
giving $100 million,
and Democrats wanted
$2 billion dollars,
and they ended up
getting north of $400 million.
The problem is, like,
it's up to states in some ways
They need the money
from the federal government,
but some states aren't
probably going to do it
because
they don't want to do it.
So you would probably
have to pass
some sort of universal mail-in
voting required legislation --
Ron Wyden and Amy Klobucha
have worked on that.
It think it has to be
a priority,
because we don't know what's
going to happen in November.
Like, there may be --
In 1918, famously,
the flu reared its head
in the spring,
it diminished
through the summer,
and then it had
its worst outbreak that fall
And can you imagine
a 50-state version of Wisconsin?
I mean, that -- it would jus
be both a public health
and democratic legitimacy
debacle.
It's a nightmare scenario
that I think Democrats
need to focus much more energy
on preventing.
-Well, I look forward to you
keeping us up to date
on all of this.
So happy that you're still
managing to do your show.
Thank you for making time
for us today.
Chris Hayes, everybody.
Check out his show every night
-Great to be on, man.